thanks everyone for coming so this is
session is on software productivity and
AI so I have to apologize for the
confusion there was a session before
this that was software software for AI
developers and this is AI for software
developers and I think that was really I
think they got the wrong title and we
got a different title so hopefully on
the right class so I also want to
introduce the three panelists they're
here
Margaret and story from University of
Victoria and premkumar Devon book from
UC Davis and also a Madison from Queens
University in Canada so welcome everyone
so I'm going to give a brief
introduction to the area and also some
of the stuff that we are doing at
Microsoft that's related to this and
then open it up to the panel to discuss
further and take it from there and given
it's a small crowd will kind of
improvise as we go in terms of how we a
lot a use of the time so first thing we
want to talk about what does software
developers look like today so you know
you can predict the future of the AI
workforce so there's been a ton of study
on data scientists and data science and
what data scientists should do and how
do engineers become data scientists how
do you data scientists become engineers
etc and you know there was a LexisNexis
did a study saying it there's going to
be 20 exabytes of data by 2020 which
means we need a lot of engineers to
process the data and how are we going to
hire those engineers which then IBM
released some numbers saying that we are
going to require 2.7 two million people
so data scientists by the year 2020 and
then McKinsey released some data is
saying that the demand for data
scientist is so much that we're going to
be 50% short and we are going to be
really short of data scientist by the
year 2020 and then they released a later
number which basically said AI
technology and tools evolve and skill
sets of data scientists will be rendered
useless in 12 to 18 months and we see
that you know people come knowing our
and some standard programming models and
by the time you know I have turned over
probably three rounds of data
scientists in the last four years
because I pick up new skills are they
don't right so so it is it is a
challenge and then finally Katie nuggets
did a survey and of ML engineers and
that 51% of them feel that they will be
out of a job
by the year 2025 because they will be
replaced by a software that can write
code itself and they're not going to
have jobs anymore so the whole data
science engineering AI space is in a
flux the definition is not very clear
what kind of people we should hire you
know what the future of that looks like
etc and it's a challenge for people like
us who hire engineers or scientists and
the kind of problems we throw at them so
hopefully through this discussion time
we can get through to some of the
interesting topics related to this area
so I want to start with the story of Oh
actually I wanted to say something about
software 2.0 actually the fourth
panelist was supposed to be on this
karpati who came up with this notion of
software 2.0 and his premise is that
large portion of the code no real-world
problems have the property that you know
you cannot write algorithms for it you
cannot write code for you they will have
input and they will have output and
develop patterns so you actually can
build a model and replace code with
models so his idea at least from the
space that is working in works a Tesla
and a lot of this is here do I make the
car automatically part or render the
windshield wipers go off automatically
there's no logic for it or if you I try
to large Loret logic for it it's very
complicated
so instead of that if I gather enough
data on the input side and then I build
a model and then produce output that
actually works and learns from the
output and goes back to the input and
kind of a reinforcement kind of learning
stuff then actually I don't have to
write code all I have to do is replace
what I would have done here with kind of
a giant neural network which I need to
train and deploy and all it is doing is
finding the right kind of code in the
program space this is directly borrowed
from his blog which will basically you
know find the right kind of algorithm
but it is somewhere in this space rather
than fighting that piece of code that I
have to write which has very complex
logic the nice thing about this idea
is that you know it is self hailing and
it's self correcting but it he say it's
all certain kinds of problems very very
well so if you talk to you know Anna's
girl K was a fellow at Microsoft I think
is a keynote later today you might talk
about it they have replaced big chunks
of code in Skype and teams would this
kind of a model where their place
thousands of lines of code with just a
few lines of model where you know the
the system is much more compact and
performs more efficiently and my own
journeyer says software engineers
started when I when I graduated from
college I was trying to figure out I did
a thesis on compiler compilers and this
is back in India and we had to type our
dissertation and it actually had to give
it a real typist that was a requirement
of the University and the typist came
back to me and said you know one too
many compilers in your in your and they
removed one compiler so wherever it said
compiler compiler we just - I wrote the
word compiler and completely described
my dissertation and you know it was
based upon this paper little later than
40 years ago by cattle basically on code
generator generator so CMU was doing a
ton of work on instead of you got em
languages and n machines and you tried
code write a code generator for a
particular language to a particular
machine you cannot be writing you to be
writing em times and compilers instead
of writing writing M times and compilers
how do you reduce that to M plus n
compilers so they have this idea of code
generator generators and this was kind
of the paper I read much later than it
was published but you know that was
before the internet and and I was in
India and so you know how long it takes
to get that paper out there but if this
paper was published today you know what
would it say a automatically generates
code that run on any machine right
because that's what you would say today
but I mean there are some truth to it as
well so when I when I started as an
intern it was a research center back in
India and you know we they hired top
graduates from the top universities in
India to do program translations a lot
of the code that you write in computer
center
time was translating code in one
language to another language so pro
writing program translators and you did
it in a human way so companies like
hewlett-packard or IBM would have
software written in one language like
COBOL you need to translate it to pl one
or you something that is written in
module I need to translate that to C or
C++ what would they do they give this
transformation rules to these engineers
who would have this card on their side
and they will actually go edit the code
and say oh I see and if left brace right
brace I'll change it if condition begin
end I mean that they physically did that
so a lot of the problems we did was of
this nature you've got a program in one
language and you need to translate a
program in another language and you know
you need to write a code generator you
wrote this code generator by hand but
you know you don't really need to write
this code generator my mentor at that
time told me that you know programmers
should get paid well but people who
generate programs should get paid ten
times as much so you don't write
programs you generate programs so that
is kind of the idea and so what you did
was you got a grammar in one language a
source language and your grammar in a
target language and then you write a
code generator generator that translates
the code from that pertains one grammar
and that satisfies the other grammar so
you note a lot of rules and if you
didn't have the grammar then you had
examples so you take examples of code in
one grammar and then you wrote rules to
map them to examples of code in another
another grammar and then you know you
got your code generator generator which
will generate a code generator which
will translate programs from one
language to another and you could
further improve that by kind of saying
here I don't want to do M by n code
generator generator so I have an
intermediate representation a standard
kernel that goes between different
grammars and so that way I have a
retarget able code generator generator
so I can reduce everything to an
intermediate form and I can do it so all
of my early programming went in writing
three transformers so we were we would
be writing three transformation rules we
would be writing three algorithms
efficient tree algorithms okay programs
the tree you navigate that really tient
lis and you write this make this
transformer cellent really really fast
so I spent a lot of time doing that and
the nice thing about it was so I can I
can quote one project where the company
I was interning at where I got paid $200
for six months of course
translated to Indian rupees they had
quoted a hundred men year that they dare
to tell you is to quote projects 100 men
years to translate everything written in
modular to UNIX NC because they're going
to hire a hundred people to manually
change the code millions of lines of
code what I did was I actually wrote it
a translate a code generator a generator
system which will generate trees in one
language and translated two trees in
another language that was done in about
two months time and the way they priced
it was they charged eighty thousand
dollars for writing the translator
generator and charge 25 cents for each
line that was translated and about three
million lines of code was translated
automatically right so this was way
before AI but at the same time I had the
satisfaction of being a part of that
project of course I got paid as I said
five hundred dollars for doing that but
those are efficient system so if I were
to do that today what would I do I cover
all of this part I have a lot more data
than before right so all of this stuff
have examples of source code in one
language examples of code in another
language I'll build this giant AI model
that'll learn from these examples and
build a transformation model and
automatically give my program translator
so that's kind of the stuff that we do
today right so in fact if you look at in
a natural language processing there's a
ton of progress that has been made in
the program language community we are
trying to learn from that and we're
trying to apply that so the recent MIT
Technology Review has a great article on
how researchers have been able to
translate between language barrier
languages languages for which there's
very little data and how they are mapped
into other languages because maybe the
past tense in the language are the verb
in the language or the combination of
urban now in the language are mapped a
certain way across the languages and you
can get an automatic translator and this
is this is really exciting for us
because we can learn from these things
which is done for natural language and
can apply to programming like
which is so so it's really a good time
to be an engineer writing compiler
systems we don't find people writing
compilers anymore but at the same time
you can do much more than just writing
standard compilers we're doing this kind
of stuff we write I want to switch gears
a little bit and say what do we do at
Microsoft so I see some of my colleagues
here some PMS and they're very familiar
with these pictures so when we think
about our developers right we think
about what we call inner loop and outer
loop so a typical developer has an inner
loop edits code bill said debugs it
that's kind of the inner loop experience
and I'm not sure if that that
terminology goes yes go ahead
we're like it seemed it seems like this
is Tom ball
I mean compilers yay because that's how
I cut my teeth too but it seems like
that's the one area that we actually
don't have we don't have a replacing
compiler writers yet but you're saying
but you're worrying me well let's do so
so that it's not actually happened I
mean I haven't seen it or maybe I'm
unaware but I mean I sort of agree that
you know it's within the scope it's a
language it's got a grammar there are
semantic rules but some like the
correctness criteria for it's much more
precise and unambiguous than say natural
language so I sort of sort of wonder I'm
a little scared by the talk so far but
I'm also like we don't have evidence yet
do we but at the same time you're not
for the challenge so with you but I'm
just saying like like that still remains
like we have all these amazing examples
like you said for natural language but
it's been actually pretty tough going we
haven't seen like huge progress in
synthesis really I mean the synthesis
has been mainly for small programs and
in in translation between languages is
still because of the semantic precision
and as sort of small differences there's
lots of corner cases and stuff so I'm
not saying it won't happen but it I
don't think it's happened yet so we're
redoing small steps so today we are
saying that's why I put up this picture
if we take very very small steps yes
the smallest step is to say hey you're
writing code can I help you write code
right that's where we start now the big
picture I'll talk about it as we go we
are not there yet
and you write that if I'm translating
from say as I have friends who are
Chinese on Facebook they one of my
friends has all his friends a Chinese
except for me and they talk in Chinese I
take their text with the Google
Translate and then what I want to write
in English I turned that to Chinese and
translate it on Google and put it back
pass it back on Facebook and they
understand what I say I'm you know nine
out of ten words might be correct there
they laugh at me once in a while but at
the same time they get the answer now if
I feed that your computer it's going to
just barf right it's it's not going to
work because now you know if you're a
program that's there is no program
that's almost correct right it has to be
character it's got to be wrong so you're
right there but at the same time you
know we can we can do stuff that
actually improves the developer
productivity helps helps the per a
developer right eighty percent of the
code and efficient ways and then put a
human do the remaining hard twenty
percent so a lot of this automation is
about doing the easy ones really well
through the machine and give the hard
ones to the human being so that they
they actually do it do it in the human
way right so that's that's kind of the
idea but we have to push the limits of
it to see how far we can go right and
come back coming back to this point so
that's kind of the inner loop of
development and I'll give you a couple
of examples if Mark and Chang you are
here they must you must have seen their
demo on intellisense on how we help
developers write a complete their code
in an outer loop you have code reviews
and testing in continuous integration CI
CD stuff release management issue
reporting documentation production
analytics all of this come with a ton of
data and we can use AI in every step of
the way here to improve the productivity
of the developer or the or the teams to
do things automatically and when I say
automatically I say do then mundane
things automatically and have the human
beings do the intelligent things so
there is a ton of stuff that can be done
automatically and today for example one
of the one of my team members had done
analysis of code review PR reviews we
found that 60% of PR reviews are
stylistic says hey you need a tab here
you need a space here you need to
capitalize your variable name you should
have more meaningful variable names it's
almost like somebody doing a paper
review the night before the reviews are
due due right so the the the conference
tears expect you to write a page full of
review and if you see that 80% of that
is all typos and and spelling
Corrections and stylistic stuff really
doesn't talk about the details and
that's kind of you know engineers are
forced to do PR reviews and they're
saying oh these are easy things I can
say about the code and I will say it and
that way I'm out of my you know I've
done with our job so that can be easily
automated and we are trying to automate
that kind of stuff
so then that has been that is hard code
reviews and maybe there's a human expert
that's required alright so for for
coming back to the point of helping the
user develop code so we have taken a
very very systematic approach to helping
developers write code so today when we
started doing this we said well you know
about 60% of what you write our API
calls today especially people doing a
lot of AI code a lot of systems code
your you have a library you import and
then you make an API call so when you
when you call a class an object of a
class or I make a class and a method
call can I predict the method that
you're going to call right that's the
first step and if I can help you with
that I significantly improve your
productivity right and to do that now we
have to make that a part of an editor so
that's Visual Studio we have scored
whatever that is and we were to make it
efficient in the sense that we are not
interfering with the developers
experience we were to make sure that it
delivers a model in a compact way so
that gets it you know not take up enough
memory on the client and also the model
comes back the inference is so fast that
you know it's not interfering with the
user experience so today we have a very
very simple model you must have seen the
demo in the mornings I'm not going to
show the demo it's basically understands
all of the program for you the control
flow you know things inside if
conditions things inside while loops
define before use etcetera etcetera
takes advantage of that and builds a
very nicely engineered machine learning
model and
works very well now it uses less than 30
megabytes of space and comes back with a
recommendation within 15 milliseconds
that's perfect but it if you want me to
make it do more things so for example if
you want to predict what argument you're
going to use when you make a method call
especially when you have overloaded
methods right now you started start to
push the limits of what this can do so
you need something more than that and if
you look at code code is kind of like
text right so which means it's a
sequence so you go left to right you
know things that you say in the left it
means things that um the right are kind
of dependent on things that are on the
left so it has kind of a sequence
sequence model very much like human text
so we have a model that is basically an
lsdm based model with attention now this
performs significantly better than
there's a regular classification model
that we have but at the same time it has
other challenges number one it is not
transparent I'm not able to explain when
it makes a recommendation what
recommendation it is making it is kind
of an abstruse model because it's
building stuff inside the thing that
it's not able to explain so explained
ability is not there but at the same
time it gives me a lot more accuracy now
if I throw a lot more data at it and lot
more coded it then I can build a very
very complex model I can use something
like a GPT - or a Bert model or Excel
net and I can understand a whole lot of
things about your code not only I
understand about code in one language
like Python or Java like I can mix them
up because almost all of the code all of
the languages have you know a notion of
a variable notion of assignment notion
of you know definition use etcetera
etcetera and I can just mix them all up
and learn the structure of your code
learn the syntax of record learn the
semantics if you good so one of the
things that happened when we built this
model on the left was that when you
built a model for c-sharp and Java right
we have a type system so we could hang
off of the type system when you're
making a method call we could say oh
this is of this type so only these
method calls will apply but when you're
working with languages like Python which
are loosely typed or no type at all we
have to figure out what the type might
be we have to create approximations for
the type so all of it had to be
engineered but when you have a model
that's as complex as this which uses a
lot of data we don't have to worry about
the types because we're learning from
patterns of the court and today we have
a model that works reasonably well and
it can actually it doesn't care whether
it's a function call or whether it's an
argument it can finish lines of code for
you it can do a lot more because and the
nice thing about throwing everything
into it is that it knows that the left
parenthesis has to be matched by life
right parentheses after four arguments
just because it has so many examples of
use of that so that's a beauty of it so
going back to Tom's point Ken can we do
that we are not there yet but I think we
are getting there and there's an
opportunity to get there so we can be
you know these are these come back with
about nineteen ninety two percent
accuracy so given enough resources given
enough cord enough given enough
complexity of your algorithms I think
you can do that so that's that's that's
what I that's what I think we can do so
what do we need to achieve all of this
thing's so first thing is data right for
us in terms of code we have tons of data
if you look at github you know you got
more than hundred million repos we've
got you know thirty plus million
contributors so you got 200 million full
requests so there's a tons of data or
that 50-plus languages of code and you
can give access to all of this stuff and
you can think you got English tags which
French sexy German text you got code in
50 different languages and you can do it
a lot of stuff with that similarly if
your Stack Overflow you got six plus
million users 12 plus million questions
and answer so when when you somebody
asks a question the answer comes with
code related to its you know we can
combine human text English text along
with code right and you got corporate
data so if I were Microsoft we got
millions of lights the lines of code
only in one piece of software like
Windows so we can do something that's
very specific to Microsoft inside
Microsoft and to build this intelligence
so basically we have tons of data and we
can take advantage of it
now to go with this data you know we
have to have analytics so one thing we
were very careful about was we didn't
throw a model at it first we see is
analyze the code deeply before we threw
a model I did so for example there are
some classes that are used all the time
there's some classes or wherever
use so if you want a high accuracy model
you focus on things that are used more
commonly patterns that occur more
commonly and you can have a simpler
model so learning code for example here
back in 71 don't include look at 18 800
Fortran programs and said 95% of the
loops are actually you have only one
line inside of them right if you have
this kind of information you can feed
the Machine this information and build
super efficient model and actually more
recently some of my colleagues in MSR
and they did analysis of 25 million
lines of code and came up with almost
the same answer which is amazing I think
so some things have not changed over
years right and we can use that to kind
of do idiom mining and stuff like that
right so anyway then we have a AI has
made significant progress we we started
with very simple models but today we
have you know our own ends and LST ends
we can use for Karuna you know to do the
kind of stuff that we are doing and we
were borrowing a ton of stuff I'm an LP
and computer vision so and we have also
tons of tools like auto ml and pie tarts
in terms of flow and then we're also as
we mind curve we are being careful that
we are not violating people's privacy
etc so we were a ton of tools for us to
build good algorithms around right and
in terms of system we have you know a
lot of GPUs available in a GPS so by
default in most of the computers today
and you know be a much faster
interconnects and we had before and we
can actually take borrow ideas from HPC
you know how do we overlap computation
with communication right how do we do
reduction in an efficient way how do we
combine you know data parallelism with
kind of model parallelism stuff like
that so we we borrow techniques from
there and we can combine all of these
things and put them together and
actually build systems that actually
work right so and finally there are
humans in the loop which we should not
forget because one of the things we
found when we deployed our models was
offline the first model or offline my
accuracy was say in the 70% and we
deployed it our PMS went and did a
survey of our customers and the
customers were quite happy and usually I
mean anybody who's done machine learning
who who does an offline accurate
70% when they deploy it online it does
just doesn't work so we did something
right and one of the things we learned
for us because we we did the user
experience was perfect right we iterated
a lot under user experience to make sure
that the models don't interfere with the
users flow users thinking flow or the
code writing flow and we made sure that
happened because the users don't care
there's AI underneath all the users care
is that you're helping them be more
efficient and more productive right so
basically my summary is you know there
are four four things that you require if
you want to build the air infused
software so one thing is you know you
know programming languages and compiler
systems the second is algorithms I
talked about good use of data in AI and
you know methods from high-performance
computing that we have to use to build
large-scale models and finally you know
user experience which is really really
important a model that's good enough
provides great user experience is much
better than a model that's perfect kind
of interferes with the users so this is
our learning from some of the automation
that we have done and to improve user
productivity and I call upon the
panelists to kind of touch upon some of
these topics in their own experience and
then we can have a discussion so we'll
start with Peggy from you know Steve
Victoria she has done a ton of work
related to user interaction in software
productivity and Peggy take it away and
while she sets up if you have any
questions comments please can you hear
me ok ok so that was the PowerPoint AI
at work there you see the way it was
doomed in on my nose I think right and
if the AI was really smart it would have
known that Peggy is a synonym for
Margaret and that into probably so
you're finding my slides here so you
remember you saw the four circles that
he had there and
human-computer interaction was the
bottom one so that's the one that I'm
gonna talk about just a little bit here
thank you very much and I want to talk
about why humans and AI need to join
forces in software development so I am a
professor at the University of Victoria
which is a short plane ride if the plane
is not canceled away up in Victoria just
across the strait here and I'm also I
work quite a bit I did some sabbatical
and I'm still doing collaboration with
the 1es team here at Microsoft and also
working with guys over in Microsoft
software research so a lot of the stuff
that I've been doing is looking at
productivity at Microsoft so I'll talk
about that during my talk here today and
first of all I want to talk about
conceptualizing productivity and what do
we mean by productivity so how do you
even define what it is how do you if you
can't really define it then how do you
measure it how do you come with the
metric how do you know that the AI
system that you're building is actually
going to make a difference if you can't
really define what productivity is so a
bunch of us from research and also some
industry partners we met in dog store a
couple of years ago now and we talked
about productivity for a week and then
we wrote a book and this is the book
that came out of it rethinking
productivity and software engineering
it's written more with practitioners in
mind and I was co-author on one of the
chapters called conceptualizing or
actually it was called a software
development productivity framework and
the goal of this chapter was to
conceptualize productivity and we came
up with this framework these three
different ways that you can think about
productivity so in the one hand you can
think about the velocity of the work and
on another hand you can think about
three hands now sorry about that other
way you can think about the quality so
that if say the number of bugs in the
system when you deploy it and then
finally you can think about productivity
in terms of developer satisfaction so
developer satisfaction is often used as
a proxy for perceived productivity and
the part of the developer because
developers do a lot of things during the
day right they don't just write code
right or test it they also review it
they help other people they they write
test cases
they go to meetings they design they
look at requirements and so on
so looking at their perceived
productivity is a good way to measure
productivity as well and while I was at
Microsoft two years ago and during the
past year and a half as well we've been
looking at trying to understand how to
measure perceived productivity on the
part of developers and out of that
research so we did a lot of observations
and we interviewed different people from
different groups at Microsoft and that
led to a big survey through which we
have this initial kind of theory about
how developer satisfaction and their
perceived productivity match to each
other and there is this bi-directional
relationship between their satisfaction
with their job and also their perceived
productivity and we build on theories
from the from management actually that
looked at and saw that there was this
bi-directional relationship so basically
what that means is if you feel more
satisfied at work you're going to feel
more perceived product productive and if
you feel more productive then you're
gonna feel more satisfied so the purpose
of this research though was to identify
what are the other factors both social
and technical factors that might
influence how developers feel about
their jobs and about their productivity
this is still working and so what we did
was we did the survey to identify these
factors to also understand how satisfied
developers were with these factors and
then we built a regression model to try
to understand which ones actually can
explain their overall satisfaction and
their productivity and let me look at
the challenges first so the other thing
that we found through this survey and
the work that we did is that there's a
lot of challenges that developers say
influence our impact negatively their
satisfaction and their productivity and
and we expected that we would see sort
of a one-to-one relationship with
challenges and then the factors in our
model that would sort of impact their
overall satisfaction and perceived
productivity but we didn't and so what
you see is that some challenges just
have this knock-on effect so for example
if you report that
your that your manager has a big impact
on your ability to work that is going to
then lead to lower satisfaction across
16 other measures and the same with team
culture if you feel that the culture of
your team is not good it's gonna have a
knock-on effect with nine other factors
which then in turn will impact the
satisfaction and the perceived
productivity of developers and so this
diagram here shows that first theory
that I showed you at the beginning which
was kind of the high level theory
relating the factors to overall job
satisfaction and perceived productivity
and after we ran the survey with I think
we heard from about 470 developers we
then created this this regression model
which then allowed us to tease out which
are the actual factors that helped
explain their their satisfaction and
which factors helped explain their
perceived productivity and just a couple
of things to note here one is that in
the terms of the key factors that
influence their perceived productivity
you see that there are many different
factors that play a role there
sure engineering tools is one of them
and that's where AI fits in right but
there are also all of these other
factors as well and then on the
satisfaction side we see that work
culture and under work culture we
clustered team culture organization
culture as well as their manager and how
collaborative their team were we see
that that actually this woman had the
most explanatory power in terms of how
they felt about how satisfied they felt
about their jobs and so when we look at
this and when we look at other research
we do know that software development is
a team sport right so a lot of the focus
that I'm seeing so far coming out about
AI and how AI can change software
engineering and change software
development is very much focused around
the individual developer and how to help
the individual developer and so what I'm
trying to do through this short talk and
maybe provoke some discussion afterwards
is thinking about can we shift and think
about how AI could help collaboration
and help the team be more productive and
and this is a picture to just kind of
demonstrate this so on the one hand if
we
focus too much on the technical aspects
so we may have this great AI that does a
really good job of producing say more
warnings I'll pick on Brendan's favorite
example here maybe more security
warnings right and so we have this AI
that shows there are all these security
warnings and and developers should
address them right before shipping the
code if you just do that and don't think
about the developers and how they're
gonna wreck and sort of deal with those
then you may hit some problems because a
lot of engineers will go I'm not gonna
fix those bugs right I'm just gonna
suppress the warnings or maybe I'm gonna
you know hide them somehow from my
manager and then carry on on the other
hand then if you if you spend too much
time just looking at the developer
humans in the loop and you forget or you
don't look at what are the the technical
opportunities that you might have at
hand then you also don't do as well as
you could so it really is this sweet
spot here in the middle that
socio-technical intersection that if you
pay attention to both just the technical
side and the soul and the human and
social side that you really will get
those gains right in terms of the
productivity so I'm really calling for
this joint optimization of both so how
can a I boost developer productivity so
if we look just on the individual side
we see a lot of examples of how AI can
automate tasks particularly rote tasks
and basically just kind of remove them
right from the developers work that they
have to do or we may see some AI that
provides cognitive support so it doesn't
completely automate the tasks but it
amplifies their cognition and somehow
someway maybe it gives them a list of
recommendations maybe it's it you know
removes the ability the need for the
engineer to keep track of a list of
things and it does that for them right
or it does some calculations or maybe
the AI will just provide some
information about system attributes that
are quality of the system or again
recommendations or maybe it provides
some feedback on personal productivity
so the AI can be watching what the
engineer the developer is doing and then
give them feedback on terms of their own
productivity with the team level in
terms of
have teams work now we have to start
taking into consideration how developers
and other stakeholders on the project
how they communicate with each other how
they coordinate their work how they
collaborate on the projects that they
have to collaborate on and also can the
AI also give them awareness of how
they're collaborating with others and
even help them reflect on their
collaborative aspects so how does AI do
that so Neal actually gave a pretty good
overview of some of the possibilities
particularly in the inner and the outer
loop and the different levels and the
different ways that AI can be used and
we're gonna hear more actually from Prem
and Ahmed on that but how how is that AI
that magical information how is that how
is that communicated to the developers
what does that look like well it may
look like a prompt it may look like a
pop-up box it may be a list of things
that you might want to choose from a set
of search results or you know or it may
be just something that's done
automatically and the developer and
engineer doesn't even have to touch it
but often AI has to be fed through
through a user interface and often
dashboards are used for doing that at
the individual and team level so looking
at telemetry data and running AI and
telemetry data that is then brought to
individual developer and stakeholders
hands so that they can look at that
information in the dashboards there's
not actually a lot of research though on
how these dashboards are used or how
they're designed so there's a lack of
research and how that's done and I'm not
going to talk about that a lot today but
we did write a short book chapter in
that or the book that I told you from
from the Dodge tool workshop and I'll
touch on that a little bit later on and
then another way that we're seeing AI
sort of making its way into the hands of
developers and in into the interplay
between developers working together is
through BOTS
through these virtual team members and I
do want to talk about these for a few
minutes so what are BOTS so this is a
definition that my student came up with
for her thesis so software bots are
interfaces that connect users with
software services
we've seen a lot of thoughts over the
last few days depending on the breakout
sessions that you went to and so
basically a bot is this interface that
may provide access to either integrated
services you know or calculations or
algorithms within the bot itself or it
may actually connect to external
services and access through an API and
the bot brings those services to the
user to use directly now of course they
also bring additional value in terms of
the AI or the intelligence that's in
them but they may also bring value by
the way that they are have a personality
the way that the bolts work with the
developers right and I'll talk about
that next a little bit in development
and software development we're seeing a
lot of different BOTS propping up so we
see BOTS wealth neil was talking about
some of the ways of synthesizing code so
we're seeing software BOTS as well
providing a way to create that code we
see test bots that are working together
in the team of developers and detecting
bugs and detecting code quality issues
and then feeding information back to the
developers perhaps in their team's
channel or in a slot channel and telling
them there are these issues or the boss
may even automatically open up bugs and
github and assign them to particular
developers depending on which part of
the code they find the code the problem
in there's also DevOps bots that
automate deployment and operation and
run the things that were manually done
before and then send messages or
communicate with the developers again
through these platforms these
communication chat platforms there are
code review bots so we were talking
about those yesterday that might
recommend changes often they're pretty
simple changes based on the code sort of
things like syntax is not syntax issues
but naming issues code review bolts may
also recommend reviewers they may wear
they're also BOTS that support into
interaction with product users so a lot
of companies are using BOTS
to actually directly talk to the users
of this software so that they don't have
to have engineer time doing that
there are documentation bots that
produce Doc's from developers artifacts
and translate them from one language to
another
there are also interestingly a lot of
entertainment bots so we heard in one of
the keynotes the other day if you want
to be productive it's good to also have
fun and it's good to take a break
so when we were studying how developers
use BOTS we found a lot of these and we
kind of chuckled but probably serves a
good a good role right and whenever I
teach and I use bots in the stuff that
I'm teaching my students always ask can
we have giffy please you know it's
important that they have these fun
things and this last one is sort of one
that I'm I don't see a lot of this but
we're starting to see it and I think we
could in the future we can have sort of
researcher BOTS that could study
individual and team productivity so
that's something that I think we'll
start to see more of there's also this
notion of chat ops instead of DevOps
where the chat ops is kind of DevOps
with this bot that also chats with the
different people in the collaboration
and I love this quote so chat ops is a
collaboration model that connects people
tools processes and automation into a
transparent workflow and this is pretty
important because the the bot is not
just doing things in the background so
it's more than just doing scripts but
it's actually communicating through the
the messaging platform with the other
developers that they have issued this
command and other developers will see
that those commands have been issued and
so that increases the level of
transparency but also increases and the
way that developers learn how to do
DevOps themselves and this is just one I
just wanted to share with you this was
one study we did with a local startup
company and Victoria and a lot of
startups are relying on bots why do you
think that is any guesses Fred in it's
cheaper than humans they want to
automate as much as they can so they're
very very clever at figuring out which
different human roles they can automate
with BOTS to make
you know make everything much more
efficient and so talking to them they
even had a bot I didn't put it on this
list that answered the doorbell so when
you rang the doorbell they would get a
message in sack that somebody was at the
door and they'd see a little picture
whoever was there and that was cheaper
than hiring somebody to open their door
right so they had thoughts that
basically connected all of the different
things that they needed to do in their
product including you know notifying
team members when errors and exceptions
occur they had thoughts that inter
interacted with their end-users many
they even had thoughts for linking their
text and phone and so everything that
they were doing was connected and came
through the same kind of platform so so
normally I'm sailing at this time of
year and the summit is always in the
middle of when I'm supposed to be
sailing and I was complaining to a
couple of people last weekend / that not
you know I I'd rather be sailing and
then preparing a talk for today and so I
thought I know I'll prepare a talk about
sailing instead of this other thing so
I'm actually gonna talk about how bolts
and how AI are actually how AI really
and how data analytics help sailing and
how maybe we could learn or take some
lessons take some analogies from that
and maybe how we could apply it to
software development teams so how many
people here are familiar with the
America's Cup a few people okay so for
those that are not the America's Cup is
probably sort of the most prestigious
sailing race in the world it's been
around since about the 1850s and America
the u.s. actually held on to the cup for
132 years and it's now this very
contentious race where you know what
there's only one winner there's a quote
I think from the first race where Queen
Victoria was watching the race and
somebody came in first and the America
came in first and she said well who's
going to be second and they sand
somebody said to her your highness there
is no second there is only first and so
this race is like really intense and
countries and syndicates now put a lot
of money into building these boats they
used to be 12 meters for most of the
race and lately they have become these
catamarans that are like up to I think
in 2017 there were 72 feet long and the
boats cost 10 million or more upwards
and the reason I'm talking about it not
because I wish I was on a boat right now
but is because we can learn a lot about
how they use data analytics and how they
use that in this team approach to
winning the America's Cup so when I was
looking at this I found some articles
and I'm sharing just some of those with
you here and I'm hoping we can kind of
discuss some of these lessons and see
how we could apply them so there are
several of ways that America's Cup
champions say sail like successful IT
teams and I'm pulling out some of these
ways or some of these analogies from
this article here so the first one is
management is important but building the
complete team is mission
mission-critical so we saw this a little
bit on my survey right that the manager
as a factor was very important in terms
of proceeded productivity but the team
was as well and so this we see this here
in sailing and this article talks a lot
about rethinking who is on the team so
you might imagine that if you look at a
team on an America's Cup boat that the
team refers to the sailors right that
are on the team but it's not just the
sailors it's everybody else around it
it's the engineers it's the training
team and in fact you know you might even
say America's cup can be sometimes won
or lost before they even launch the boat
that's going to raise because so much
engineering goes into it but I also want
to put out there that we can think about
these BOTS that are really a user
interface to the AI that we're trying to
build right for developers to use that
we can think of those also as virtual
team members so this AI that we're
building or could build can become like
a virtual team member in the team so
that's just one way the second way that
they talked about is that winning teams
embrace disruption so the America's Cup
teams over the years that
didn't sort of spy and what the other
teams were doing and see the new
technology that they were using that
they would lose right they just would
not be able to keep up and the
engineering systems team needs to
respond at the speed of opportunity and
in the preparation for these races so
the more recent America Cups boats and I
don't know if you can see this in this
picture but they actually they're more
like they're flying than sailing because
they have this technology the New
Zealand team did this first you know
they had this this this insight that if
they built this what they call a foil
between the two the two holes of the
catamaran that they would get lift right
from the water and as they reach as they
go over 18 knots the boat lifts up and
it literally flies over the water and
they can get you know going like just
crazy speeds like over 60 kilometers an
hour or even maybe it's miles an hour
and so the boats when as as soon as
somebody comes with something you have
they have to jump at the speed of
opportunity to really be able to work
that effectively so what disruptions
have we seen in software development so
Neal touched on a few what are the big
disruptions do you think we've seen in
software engineering and I look at the
people who are have been around a bit
longer I can help you out if you want
yeah the whole continuous deployment and
what about what what enabled that can ya
automation the cloud right the internet
right email containerization right so
these disruptions are changing the game
right they're changing the the speed at
which we can deploy and you know another
one that I wanted to just touch on a
little bit is the use of social
technologies and the use of the cloud
and how developers communicate with each
other so I'm referring here to some
studies that I did that looked at how
developers particularly in open-source
no longer sort of you know sit in their
room and write their own code but they
actually are part of a big community and
they learn and they help other people
and so you
this what's called a participatory
culture of software development so a lot
of my friends that are not software
engineers will say you know software
debt developers they're so antisocial
they don't talk to other developers they
just sit in the basement and I'm like no
not today developers have to be very
social and they have to know how to use
these tools and how to use something
like stack overflow so imagine not
having Stack Overflow today so this is
another example of a disruption and I
don't think that we were really aware
that it was happening while it was
happening it was just something that
caught a lot of people off-guard and we
had to just kind of rush to keep up so I
think with AI that we're gonna have what
kind of culture is AI gonna lead to in
teams right so I don't know I bet I
think it's something we need to think
about ok so going back to the sailing
analogies this is this one is it's all
about the data
so in this America's Cup team so I'm
referring back here I think this was
from the 2013 team the their boat had a
thousand IOT sensors on the boat and
they were producing something like 10
gigabytes of data an hour when they were
sailing pretty incredible that foil that
I talked about had 300 sensors on it
just on that and so they're using this
data basically to fine tune not not just
the engineering of the system or the
boat that they're it's a system actually
that they're sailing on but to fight but
also to fine tune what the crew are
doing right and to learn what's going to
make the boat go faster
learning from the different sea
conditions learning from the different
wind conditions and then putting that
all together in models and then using
that to help them win and one of the
things they talked about is that within
the team that every individual within
that team needs their own unique
dashboard so that they can sort of pull
out from that dashboard an understanding
of what it is that they are contributing
to the project and I think in software
development as well that we need to kind
of think about what kind of unique
dashboards do we need to support the
different people on the team and of
course the need for explainable AI comes
up but it's not just explainable AI to
one person but it's explainable AI from
one kind of stakeholder to a different
kind of stake
right so having them somebody in the
middle have to do that explanation and
the other thing about data that they
talk about is really important is
supporting post-mortems by the entire
team so one of the things that they do
is they sit down after the race or after
they've been practicing they sit down
and they play through everything they
did and they look at the data and the
whole team again is there and they look
at what could we have done differently
what could we have done better and in
particular they did a post-mortem after
this race and actually this wasn't even
a race this was a training session I
don't know if anybody saw this in the
paper and the time but this was a team
Oracle for the USA and the the sale
actually on this boat is not made of
fabric it's it's stiff and you can see
the foils underneath there so they
decided to push or the the skipper
actually decided to just push it just a
little bit further to see you know what
can this boat really do and pushed it
just a little bit more and then the
conditions changed which happens in life
right and the boat sank and it's this
amazing I've got some links here if
you're there it's fascinating to read
this boat thank God
dragged out underneath the San Francisco
Golden Gate and it was going to be blown
out to sea anyway eventually they
managed to get it back in but they they
lost months they lost thousands and that
not just millions but they lost the time
before the race to be able to train for
the race because of this but they do say
if something doesn't break it's too
heavy and so they do try to push right
what they're doing so I'll come back to
that again
so another analogy that I like from this
article is that great ideas come from
the front lines so they don't design the
technology for these boats and for these
sailors that have to actually sail the
boats in laboratories just right I mean
obviously they do a lot of the
engineering work in the laboratory and
they do a lot of simulations but they
also go out onto the boats with the
sailors and they watch what they do in
race time and also in training time so
they learn a lot from doing that and I
want to push and I know Neil is doing
that with his teams so that it's
important to observe how developers are
using the AI and a day-to-day basis not
just individually but as part of the
team to understand how we can improve it
more and in terms of sort of that
frontline thing here's an example of
something that you might you might learn
so on my boat we call my Auto helm so my
Auto helm is is just basically a
mechanical thing i sat in a compass
direction or I can connect it to the GPS
and it steers the boat so we don't have
to steer the boat and we call it auto
and we personify auto and and actually
this blog post talks about the same kind
of thing and when Auto screws up we say
well autos cranky today you know like
why why did Auto screw it up
screw us up right and but we call our
GPS the GPS and I always wondered like
why why do we you know give a name to
the the Auto helm but everything else is
just the GPS or the depth sounder and
this blog post actually shed light on
this for me so the the blog the writer
of this blog post he explains that on
their boat the Auto helm the automation
that takes over the auto hem is like a
crew member so it is doing something
that decides where the boats gonna go
and actually affects kind of their their
life right it's taking over what what a
crew member would do and so this is the
kind of thing that you can learn when
you go on the front lines that maybe you
know some of the AI should be under the
covers right but maybe some of the AI
should be as part of a bought within the
channel where there's awareness and
transparency and conversation and
feedback and so on happening and then
the idea that it's all about just you
know the Machine kind of you know or you
know the data or engineering winning the
race it's not at the end of the day it
does come down to people but it comes
down to people and how they're supported
by the technology so it really is this
effective sort of integration this is
just you know the skipper saying that
yeah he made the mistake you know that
that led to them losing one of the races
and I just want to also mention this
this quote because I really like this
one and I think some people have seen
that cyclical graph right that shows the
a
I HDI every time there's an AI winter
HCI labs go up and then then AI jumps
again and that rather than doing this
cycle that we need to really think about
addressing both of these at the same
time so that HCI doesn't have to come in
and clean up the mess right that the AI
researchers leave behind okay and I put
some discussion points for the panel but
we can maybe come back to these later
but I do think that we need to think a
lot more about how AI can enable but are
an AI enabled BOTS can support or even
potentially harm software team
collaboration and communication I
haven't talked about the risks in this
talk I've done that in other talks but
there's lots of risks and we've heard
about lots of them at the other
breakouts
how can engineering system and
development teams together embrace and
evaluate disruptions from the AI so on
the America's Cup team the engineering
team and the sailors are one team and I
think that in development we could think
about that a lot more as well have a lot
more closer collaboration between
engineering team and the end the
developers themselves and I didn't talk
a lot about dashboards but I do think
that this is an interesting future piece
of work how these dashboards these AI
infused dashboards could support
tactical decision making support
operations and also post mortems and how
they could be personalized and how we
could study them and by the way I do
think we could use BOTS to study right
some of these things as well so I pass
it to you
so while I set up prime square enix
frame slides if anybody has questions
for Peggy comment yeah that's that's
very much a work in progress and it's a
really interesting question yeah yeah I
mean I think right now the way that BOTS
are being used and being designed it's
very ad hoc so it's kind of like here's
an idea for a bot let's let's write one
and let's deploy it and then see see how
it sticks and see how it's being used
and I think it could be useful to take
more of an engineering or architecture
or system perspective on the BOTS and
understand where they play and really
think about should this be a bot you
know there is conversation enabled or
should it just be you know and I think
I'm kind of thinking in API terms it's
when when would this thing want to
interact like another human with this
yeah that's the really interesting
things yeah really super interesting
yeah okay so thanks for the invitation
it's my pleasure to be here and talk
about this area so this is kind of
taking over my life for the past eight
years or so okay so let me just explain
what this term naturalist means there's
some confusion about this particular
term so you know so the way I like to
explain it is that like human speech and
writing have evolved you know over
thousands of years to to serve certain
national human purposes and the kind of
structure and use of these human
languages you know I'll talk about where
they come from but what we've discovered
is that the same kinds of structures and
patterns of usage also exist in code so
now what does that mean right so when
you think about
natural language you know a good example
is this guy here is about to have a very
bad day and you know let's say his
children are on the side of the pool and
so how is he going to react to this
right so is he going to sit up and
recite some think of some glorious poem
and recite it or is he just simply going
to say you know get out of here right so
so this is kind of the imperative under
which natural languages evolve they've
evolved to communicate very efficiently
and quickly in noisy dangerous and
distracted environments now what does
this have to do with cord now this fella
here let's assume that for a moment that
he's actually a developer and that
person is actually his manager right so
is this is this chap now going to go off
and think of glorious continuations and
monads and recursive this is and that or
is he just going to write the loop that
he wants to write the simplest and most
mundane way he can think of right so a
lot of coding gets done under these
circumstances and it's not just simply
the coding as you'll see later it's when
people think about what kind of code
they want to write it's not just
themselves they're thinking of right
that also relates to natural language
because when I'm speaking I'm not just
simply thinking about myself and how I
want to construct my utterances I'm also
thinking about the listener and how
they're going to react to my utterances
so in that sense speaking is a very
cooperative act because and a very
conscious and mutually conscious act and
so is coding so so essentially what
natural means here is that human
utterances in human speech are
constructed in noisy dangerous and
distracted environments and as a result
the way we speak is highly repetitive
very predictable and can be modeled
statistically right and this is
wonderful because this is what enables
things like Google Translate speech
recognition and the forms of tools that
have made all these wonderful advances
in natural language processing so code
is a little bit different right so code
is primarily intended to run on machines
so
when a programmer here is writing code
they're sort of in some sense the end
intent of it that is actually executing
a machine machines don't really care how
you write it it doesn't matter whether
you write I less than 10 or 10 bigger
than I or I plus 1 or 1 plus I it
doesn't really matter and she can has a
lot of flexibility in how she chooses to
write her code so so far
not much call for naturalness right but
in fact the cords actually maintained by
another developer and when the quarter
writes code she is thinking about who's
going to maintain the code and how the
maintainer is going to read the cord and
in fact when the maintainer reads the
cord it's really a noisy Channel right
so maintained errs are not computers
maintainers don't do operational
semantics or denotational semantics in
their head they're actually genuinely
reading in a noisy channel environment
so by this I mean actually mean the
Shannon noisy Channel right so when a
developer reads cord she's thinking to
herself this is probably the computation
that their developer intended to write
the maintainer hypothesizes and then the
maintainer says if the developer were
meaning to implement this computation
what's the most likely way that she
would have implemented it so I'm really
sort of recapturing the Bayesian
formulation of the 9c channel model
right so she's gonna guess how would she
have implemented this and she's gonna
look for those bits in the cord and if
those bits are not there she's gonna say
well she must have done been doing
something else he's gonna help but
there's a different computation that the
developer may have intended and she's
gonna see how think about how that would
have been implemented so it really is
the noisy Channel right you're not
computing semantics directly from the
program using an operational Channel
you're guessing meanings that's how
people read code anyway and I can't
prove this but this is just my
hypothesis right so this formulation is
called we call it the deu model because
it's came out of a discussion between
people at UC Davis and Edinburgh and UCL
so Charles Sutton at Edinburgh and Albar
at UCL so we don't have quite have a
name for this formulation these times we
call it by mortal comprehension
sometimes we call it to channel
comprehension we're not sure you
the cool thing is that this the second
channel here is really actually a noisy
channel and there's a lot of interesting
questions that come up out of this so
right okay so because of this noisy
channel that exists in code and because
it's not formal operational semantics
base software as it is used is a
repetitive predictable and amenable to
statistical modeling because the same
imperatives that applied to the
construction of natural language
utterances apply to the construction of
code okay all right so so what right so
so what it's taken over the last eight
years of my life right and there are two
aspects to this the first aspect which
I'm not going to say a lot about because
I got the sense that really I should
talk more about the engineering aspects
of this in this forum but this is I
spend more than half my life these days
on the scientific aspects of this and we
do a lot of human subjects studies we're
doing a lot of corpus Studies and maybe
even done some eye tracking studies so
how does correlate to human preference
and and performance right so you know
people never say bread and butter for
butter and bread for example they always
say bread and butter right nobody ever
writes I equals 1 plus I right so those
things are actually related and relates
to the noisy Channel right you expect
certain computations to be written in
certain ways and if you read it a
different way it actually impedes
comprehension and impedes impede smooth
easy reading of course
so we're doing a lot of human subjects
studies in this area we just finished a
mechanical turk study with 70
participants trying to figure out if we
can predict which forms of writing code
would be preferred by human beings and B
and we can the and the next step is for
us is to do to determine with what
accuracy we can prefer how people would
prefer the C code being written and then
after that we're going to do some coded
comprehension studies to see if we can
predict which code is going to be easier
for human beings to understand and which
kind of code is going to be harder for
human beings to read and this work is
being done in collaboration with Emily
Morgan who is a psycho linguist
UC Davis and so this is very exciting
for us because she's generally been
studying forms of expression in natural
language using a theory called rational
speech act theory and we're now trying
to apply that same theory to code but
that's all I'm going to say about it I'm
happy to discuss it more if anybody's
interested in in the in the in the panel
discussion all right so the other part
of my life is trying to explore the
engineering question how do you exploit
code repetitiveness to help programmers
so the first paper on this was written
about eight years ago in our group and
you know so we exploited some
interesting properties to do some
application so I'll talk more about the
applications for the rest of this talk
okay so you know the basic general
scheme is you know as Neil mentioned is
that you know this is sort of the way
people used to build tools you think of
a tool and the developer decides okay I
need this tool so she goes off and
writes a tool and then the tool can
process source code and produce results
so a lot of you know tools fit into this
framework right so the twist here is
that because now we have this property
of naturalness you can take a large
court corpus estimate various kinds of
statistical models and these critical
models can then improve the performance
of the tool so this is sort of the
framework for a lot of the tools and the
you know the details depend upon the
model you want to build the data you
have and how the model improves the
performance of the tool okay so you know
there's lots of applications the first
application that we did in back in 2011
was called suggestion I know and that's
basically you estimate a model like that
and there are various ways to do models
we've kind of switched over to
completely using you know neural network
based models these days but you know
there's lots of ways to estimate these
models and you know obviously there's
lots of data there's quite a few papers
that that have described this we have
something on github you can welcome to
use it's called SLP core a lot of people
are using it
it's until very recently some very
recent work from from
from from Edinburgh this was our model
was the best profiling model so so one
very interesting problem in court that
doesn't occur in natural languages
vocabulary explosion so in natural
language as you scan more and more tests
that the Cadbury starts to grow slower
and slower and eventually it saturates
it's only like place names and people
names that begin to grow but every new
model of court introduces new vocabulary
so there's a real problem in vocabulary
and until very recently be planning
models were terrible at it
you have to cap the vocabulary are
essentially the number of parameters he
of the train is is becomes unmanageable
the recent work from from Karen Paterson
Sutton show how to deal with vocabulary
explosion in D planning models using
something called byte pattern coding
which is a way of splitting up
identifiers and and doing this quite
efficiently so this is kind of I guess
the the sort of the first application
that has been was done and I was great
to see it being used now and shipped and
actually apparently being used by
millions of users I saw a demo of
intelligence and it was it was great to
see that the big thing that has come up
and a largest JavaScript the obfuscation
it's I put the office Keshan in courts
because it's not really the obfuscation
is basically replacing you know dumb
names with better names so you know
people are people minify Java code and
chips out and you can recover the names
from it and so this is basically
estimating a model of this sort you know
estimating clear code using minified
code by the way all these models you
know this one and that one need data for
estimation and you know and all these
things you have huge amounts of data
it's not really a problem you know once
you have a tool the best minification
you know you can produce as much data as
you want to do this task and you know
again there are various kinds of models
the first one in the along these lines
was
a model based on conditional random
fields from Rachel vitality th we've
done some work along these lines using
free space translation that works in a
complimentary way to the CRF work from
Revit also and actually if you put the
two together you get much better
performance the same technology is now
being used for recovering identifier
names from binaries in decompiled
binaries so it's it's a pretty useful
thing the other kind of exciting
application is gradual typing so gradual
typing is a framework where developers
it's sort of a compromise between Java
like languages where everything has to
be declared in Python like languages
where nothing has to be declared this is
a way where you add declarations to suit
yourself to sort of like look for errors
in places where you think that you might
make typing errors so this estimates a
model of this type estimate the type
this distribution the type given the
name and the context so a lot of people
have used context more recently this
year there's some work on using the name
of the variable to estimate this
distribution and there's a bunch of work
in this area we've done work on this so
there's been work from ETH and Michael
throttle has now a Schrute card has also
done work in this area so these are some
of the emerging early applications of
this the first applications but there's
a there's a lot of there's a lot of work
to be done
along these lines so so this is sort of
like the simplest model you can think of
and it turns out this is actually quite
useful and that's for checking code
right so so you can just simply estimate
a model over a large corpus and if the
model says the code is weird it turns
out this actually you know quite quite
accurate in finding finding defects so
this was the paper in Dixie 2016 and in
our lay enough I mean it's not a fair
comparison but oddly enough this is
about as good as many things like fine
bugs
of course fine box tells you what do you
thinks is wrong this doesn't tell you
anything except saying this looks weird
right so so so this is kind of the
simplest possible thing but it turns out
you know already is
arguably useful so this was the
suggestion thing that I talked about
earlier variable name recovery this can
be used to you know again you can
estimate this with any large corpus and
so you can use this to either recover
names as in the context of be efficient
or you can use it to check whether using
an improper valuable name so this is the
the gradual typing problem and you know
again I talked about this and it sort of
again can be trained from large amounts
of data and so so far these are sort of
what you know what Neal was talking
about is with this inner circle stuff
there's also kind of more outer circle
stuff that relates more to like not
immediate coding but more sort of
process oriented things so interestingly
there's lots of data on these lines and
there's been a number of papers coming
out recently that allow you to to repair
code so so there's been a few different
experiments using some standard data
sets to see how well machine learning
models can pass code
most of the existing work on automatic
code patching has been using genetic
approaches in other words you sort of
have the hill-climbing search searching
over a lot of possible patches trying to
find something that can actually patch
your defect the new approaches involve
no search or very little search so
they're much more efficient it's
basically you train a translation model
using large amounts of data from github
that talked about how you know typically
the datasets use one-line patches and
they train a translator to translate
from all quote in new code using
sequence to sequence models or transfer
transformer model so there's most of the
recent work is now we have anyway anyway
most of our work now has been using
transformers and they're they are not as
powerful and successful as the genetic
approaches but they're much quicker so
so this is kind of interesting
stuff to do so the data can be trained
using commit data you can also simply do
you know things like denoising
auto-encoder and so on and so forth and
we've done some experiments with large
datasets of student programs and
denoising auto-encoders can correct
about 50 to 60 percent of student errors
so that's those those are syntax errors
so this is another kind of interesting
area of research then this is the so
this is essentially producing English
from code and there's some interesting
issues here that there are that are
going on right so there's there's useful
comments and there's useless comments
right so so there's for the kind of
comments that are needed by somebody who
is unfamiliar with the code is one thing
the kind of comments that are needed by
people who are familiar with the code is
something else altogether so in other
words you know if the code is written
the way you expect it to be written
right then this comment is sort of most
useful to people who were unfamiliar
with it but sometimes the court is not
written the way you expect it and then
you really need comments to explain what
the court is doing so there's a
summarization and there's commenting
they're two different things and so
Charles Sutton has some very interesting
work where he tries to say if the
English is predictable from the code
that the comment is predictable from the
court then it's actually probably
useless comment for most people right so
so there's some interesting stuff going
on here and we don't quite know how to
classify the two kinds of comments the
comment that is really a little add one
to I who cares right
whereas something more complex like you
know resync the lock or something like
that which is not what you expect I
equals I plus 1 to be doing right so so
that's an interesting question then this
code retrieval I mean I you know now
we're really far away from sort of the
singularity of all this this is mostly
about like you know for example using
Stack Overflow data so that you give
some English description and you can
find the code
there are some very interesting problems
here we've just finished a code snippet
parser in typer so we can type and parse
cord snippets with very high accuracy so
that you can take fragments on
stackoverflow and you know what type the
bits are and you know what syntax it is
so we can do it with well over 95%
accuracy so and so you need that because
if you're trying to paste some code from
Stack Overflow to retrieve some cord and
paste it you wouldn't need to be able to
parse it and type it and then finally
you know given some code recommend a
person and this is for tasks various
kinds of tasks assignment so this is
very interesting we've now managed to
train language models specifically
individual developers in a project so
you take it take a general language
model trained over large code corpus you
know and then specialize that model for
each developer so given a code fragment
we can score each developer so that we
know you know how familiar that
developer is with that code fragment and
this you know we haven't you know we
welcome collaboration on this so we're
trying to apply to recommend code
reviewers but I think there's lots of
other potential applications let's say
for example you get a warning on a piece
of cord and you know you don't
necessarily want to go ask the person
who implemented the cord or the person
last change the code to comment on it
because that person may have committed
to that module but they may not have
touched that money in a long time so
what you'd like to know is who's written
code like this and language models are
pretty good at supporting that so we
welcome partners on this because it's
it's kind of hard to do that particular
experiment whether you're recommending
the right person to fix a warning using
open source code so you know if
anybody's interested we'd be happy to
work with you on this so so this is just
some examples there's a lot more stuff
we're doing some stuff would recommend
to determine validity of invariants you
know I think there's there's a lot of
opportunities so anyway these are all
different types of probabilistic
probabilistic models now how exactly you
approximate
these probabilities from data sets you
know there's a lot of ways to do that so
there's many different models you know
so there's you know discrete traditional
models in Grand Aryans there's tree
based models like pcfg and TS GS
probabilistic context-free grammars and
trees tree structure grammars there are
faith-based translation models that
there have been used this conditional
random fields and of course you know now
a lot of attention is being paid to
these deep learning models lexical
models sequence to sequence models
sequence tagging models so as the
difference between these two is a
sequence tagging model the input and
output length is identical so in part of
speech tagging for instance or when you
want to assign types to variables
we only guess types of variables the
inputs and output sizes are equivalent
so these models generally tend to
perform better because the the length is
conserved anyway
transformers are becoming very powerful
and we've had a lot of success with them
we hope to have some papers coming out
soon with them they're very easy to
train they're very efficient their
enormous capacity so it's pretty
promising and gated graphing a lot work
so these models are very promising and
powerful but they're very slow so
there's some recent work at Google where
they have managed to speed these think
quite a bit using data structure layouts
we're also doing some experiments trying
to find ways to speed up the training of
the aircraft networks so as there's lots
of ways to approximate these functions
that that I showed you in the previous
slide and and you know it's all about
finding enough data to train it so there
are various issues that this I'm going
to stop with this slide this is this is
some of the issues that that are faced
in court so one big problem in court is
vocabulary proliferation and the DP
seems very promising and we're getting
good results with that as well we've
been able to replicate the results from
from certain competitors even in some
cases improve on it
so maybe that is the solution I don't
know another big problem is explained
ability so so I actually learned a few
things that this at this faculty seminar
that I'm really eager to go back and try
so you know when you suggest a patch to
a programmer or you suggest a type 4 in
a gradual typing environment or you
suggest a change or something along
these lines or just you just give a
normal course suggestion it'd be nice to
have some explanations of why you're
doing that especially with patching and
also with like saying this code looks
bad you should fix it it'd be nice to
have some examples and I think there are
ways to deal with this but I think this
is really exciting and interesting open
area and finally um so I think that sort
of in some sense the most exciting thing
about cord is the fact that it has both
operational semantics and noisy channel
going on right so you're writing court
for the computer and writing code to
actually to actually be read by a human
being and so there's a probabilistic
side to cord and then there's a
deterministic formal side to code so how
do you exploit these two things together
I think some of the most exciting work
in this area is gonna come out of that
so stop there questions have they gone
over or sorry the last speaker I said
hopefully can stay for a few minutes
longer so that we can get through the
talk and I'm gonna had some really
interesting things to say related to
data and some of the work he did with
the companies he wrote with okay okay
yeah thanks so much giving a run in to
break at least five minutes so hopefully
can stay for that okay I'm gonna try to
do this talk in the two minutes
okay so basically so this is my lab we
are the software analysis intelligence
lab and what I want to do today is I
want to talk about primarily our
experience of actually having machine
learning models that actually software
developers have been using so some of
these are systems actually not what I
was thinking about I've been used for
the last ten years or actually a decade
of systems that was using machine
learning on software engineering data
and can our experience some more how
developers have actually found them now
quick overview so software developers
produce quite a bit of data so things
like code changes release notes bug
reports email discussion code reviews we
call these development repositories but
as well users as well produce a lot of
data so things like crashes locks or
limit reads reviews okay we call these
field repositories okay another type of
data as well a people use so online code
Stack Overflow github so all that
information today unfortunately is only
one way right the data doesn't call back
in your next decision-making process the
simple thing is think of Amazon how
Amazon tells you when you buy a you buy
B you could do that same thing for
software developers when you change a
people whenever people change your a
they change B so now this is an area
that kind of been going for many years
it's called basically the mining
software repository community so the
mining software repository community now
has been around 20 years it should
actually consider one of the top 10
venues by a by Google Scholar for
systems research ok so there's many many
people that have been doing stuff on
this I'm just giving you a flavor that's
influencing about what I'm doing but if
you're interested in this so we do check
this community ok so I said so many
companies are actually use this today in
practice so these are some of them okay
now really at the end of a this there's
data there's a model and where we care
about it's two things so we care about a
decision and we care about insight now
the decision is kind of like you want to
say okay it's this piece of code buggy
or not okay so that's binary but
actually for developers and we talk to
managers you don't care as much about
this one they care about how to improve
the process in the future right so
that's actually where the insight comes
in right for them the insight is more
important for them actually that the
decision for this bug because that will
only fix this
specific one right so now I'm gonna give
you some flavors of that so ideally what
you want is when a new coat change comes
in you want to be able to flag it right
so red yellow green so red means there
is something really bad about this go
change yellow you know this looks a bit
kind of worrisome guys green is go ahead
commit that okay now we were lucky
actually that we work through his
blackberry on this project and what they
had is they had for their developers for
every coat change so this was done on
the device software for the BlackBerry's
they would actually rank manually the
change whether it's high risk or low
risk okay
now I want to emphasize something which
is we learn is for them he didn't care
about buggy or not buggy he actually
cared about risks which means much
bigger influence and just buggy or not
buggy for example a change might be
super simple you updated the UI but for
some reason that change is touching a
piece of code order required the whole
codebase to be recertified by actually
the the carriers so we'll push the whole
release by a couple of months it's a
very simple change but it's a high-risk
change so now the idea is we have all
these changes here we have risk
classifications so wouldn't it be nice
that actually we will learn from this
build a model so now when a new change
comes in we can actually predict that
right so and that's exactly what we did
so we took one year of changes okay and
we actually would pass them through the
human developers and we'll pass them for
the model and then we actually get this
is the risk that actually the developers
did there's a system there this is the
risk that actually the developers did
and it's point eight for correlation
correlations go from zero to one zero
means it's random one is means it's
perfect so actually we got a good
correlation here now this was actually a
study where we the student was there for
a year so actually he looked at around
450 developers doing that across 60
teams now an interesting thing we
learned out of this is actually what
they did when they started using it
didn't only they didn't only depend on
the automated system they actually
dependent on both of them so they
treated both of them as different
experts so if the developer says this is
high risk
and then the our system says low risk it
will still be high risk and the other
way around if we say it's low risk
developer says is high-risk right so
this is an example where it's not always
about you know the system is right and
you want to replace it it's more to
support the human now this type of work
has actually been kind of there's an
open-source project called commit guru
which you can actually go in and
actually upload your it will analyze
your codebase and I will give you that
type of analysis now a lot of companies
as well have adopted this so Ubisoft
does that and many other companies now
actually have developed this in-house
that now this is the Ubisoft is done
independent for my team and many other
companies have done that okay now
another so this is our call that gets
the inner loop now when you talk about
the outer loop is they're gonna look at
actually at testing and very large-scale
testing so think of Amazon do you don't
only want to make sure that one user can
buy a book you want to make sure that a
million people could buy a book and
nothing could go wrong now the problem
today is a lot of these tests the way
they're they're verified that the pass
is did anything crash nothing crashed
we're good right well that's probably
not the best way to go about it so we
wanted to actually leverage some of the
data that's produced from these tests
okay so simple thing is you have a
sequence of events like let's say it's
Oh logs in this case so we do a lot of
log analytics and you know so we have
event two so acquiring a log it's all
about releasing a log
so really what happens is we do this so
we look at actually what's happening in
the test and we because it's a test we
expect to be very repetitive so if we
see any deviations from the
repetitiveness we can actually flag it
now the beauty of this is we actually we
and actually most developers don't
exactly know how the system runs at
scale but actually recovering that
information with the logs we can
actually flag look that this e six
happen and it shouldn't happen okay so
now what really happens is you actually
the output out of this is something like
this so says this log message here so
this is the Dell DVD storage that is a
application used by Dell to actually
benchmark their servers so and so it's
basically like a DVD store so you're
entering a per se so 98% of the time
this message is followed by this long
message is followed by this long message
one percent of the time this log
messages fall by this message
and your 358 times this sequence is
followed and then what happens is
actually all these sequences are sorted
right so the highest one here like this
one here the one I expanded actually
shows you the most weirdest kind of
sequence that we have seen so then what
happens is the tests are now can copy
and paste this this HTML kind of
document and email to a developer and
ask them okay what's happening in here
good so this arrived you know
ninety-eight ninety-nine point nine
percent reduction the view log files
okay and the procedure is quite high you
know 56 to 100 percent now what was nice
about this is we actually give them as
well an example of exactly like that
sequence of what went wrong in there now
you could take that same log sequencing
and you can start adding time on it okay
so we know event what event will ABCD
happen together now we can say you know
it took this sequence like five seconds
okay now we've seen that so many times
so now we can create a distribution okay
so the on the black here on the black s
on the left side is one actually a run
and on the right side is another run if
you can see them because of the red here
it is actually a bit slow or this run
can put it other one okay and then here
we'll actually lays it over time again
send here what it's saying is you know
we want to make sure maybe because what
could happen is over time the system
might be getting bad right or in this
case it's always bad here okay
okay so this was an example actually in
my sequel there was a bug in my sequel
so this actually eventually got fixed
okay so these are some examples of
actually how we have used this data some
of these systems were actually being
used as I said for last ten years
okay so the question is what's the
secret for long term and does your
adoption
so is it highly scalable top-performing
models and the answer is actually not
really the case and I'm gonna spend the
next slide which is actually the last
slide to explain at least my father but
really what makes some of these things
work okay one of the things that's
special about we have is the hobbies we
have a human in the loop a lot of the
decisions we give them is now this
person has to go to somebody up and
manage
to save example we're not gonna release
the system we're not going to do this
release now it's very hard to go I
cannot do this release because this deep
learner is saying no right so they
really need to be have something that
supports their decision because the
manager will say get out of my room okay
so this is kind of one of the big
challenge here is how do you make that
now there are two things so what I would
say a domain challenges and some of them
are actually machine learning challenges
and I'm gonna go through them kind of
one at a time so one of the tricks I
think we found is it's really important
that the decision or whatever the
machine learning system gives you is
assignable to somebody so an example for
that is in this bug in the in the system
I would actually say look this is a
buggy change what was good about that is
two things is we actually were able to
tell we had a specific person which is
this developer that did the change where
we can say this is your problem deal
with it which was very different and
prior work in the area which barkaneers
okay before the release analyze all your
code changes and flag buggy files and
non buggy files the question is okay so
you know this file is super buggy so who
do you give it to right where is this
one it's your problem deal is your
hopper there okay so that was one thing
the other thing too is timely so again
I'm gonna use that example just for time
but the it applies for the other ones to
you is we did it right there you have
because it happened inside the IDE like
you had that files open you could deal
with it now right but when you say look
this file that had 50 people that worked
in it some of them work there are like a
couple months ago it's troublesome it
was much harder to do that now machine
learning challenge so explainable is a
key thing and the reason we want the
models to be explainable is a lot of the
developers and managers don't only care
about this release they care about the
long term you know if there's something
we're doing bad we want to be able to
flag it and improve our processes and
this is what the explain ability was a
key thing now another one that actually
I've recently started relies is this
idea of trust so let's say you have you
have a lot of data raw data okay and
over the years developers are smart and
they've actually did
their own scripts and their own I would
say none a imodels just some warning
signals that they know about so they
have a script that runs over all the raw
data and if that script says something
is bad the deep trust that system right
so now you have two ways you can go the
deep learning idea which is just take
all the raw data okay
or you go to this simple way let's take
there what I would say trustable dumb
models which one would you go is right
so intuitively you say well let's take
all the raw data get the human out of
the loop but instead actually it is much
more easier to get the system adopt at
least in our experience where you say
look this is based on a combination of
all your basic models you trusted all of
these and we just built on top of your
trust so that was one essential thing
okay and the other thing is this
maintainability aspect um and a lot of
corporations the the machine learning
team there's like one or two big teams
and these teams have to go from
different you know to help a group and
then they need to go out like more of a
consulting setup right so the idea is
your models you want to be able to set
them up leave not every two days get a
phone call hey can you come and help us
tweak the parameters right so this is an
essential part as well okay so that's
your like my big views on like really
what I felt kind of worked and why some
of these systems have been used for many
years like you know this is systems we
use to almost ten years now I want to
think about it and we are never really
called in to tweak the models on there
right okay so is that in mind this is
kind of basically what I talked about
today so I talked I introduced about
this idea of the mining software
positive community and how there's so
much data today and you can actually
look at that data and produce it and
reuse it to actually make your next
decision I'll give you an example can
how you could use the data about prior
changes to actually detect whatever
changes high risk or low risk I'll give
you another example as well how to use
logs so that outer loop aspect they
actually attack performance problems and
a system by actually mining these logs
which are rarely ever used and then I
walk through very rapidly of some of the
reasons why I think is more
essential to focus on these over just
blindly the performance of the model
itself okay so that's it and what is
that ten minutes you're five minutes
before today